[Applause]
guys
um there's been big news in the
podcasting world
huge news in the podcasting world the
pod father himself
the king is moving out of los angeles
that's huge big time joe rogan is
leaving los angeles he's moving to texas
um and it's crazy i was talking to him
this weekend he sent me some pictures of
of like his his spot
it's gonna be like a ranch i assume dude
it's sick obviously uh you know
obviously we can't show any pictures but
like it's sick it's the [ __ ] dream
he's got a the studio looks insane
because he's gonna do the podcasting
there as well
and i'm pretty sure there's a permanent
move for him like
100 and it's a really interesting thing
because
with covit or corona
you realize what the point
of living in a big city was right so the
point of us living in new york city was
always
to chase our career now we can't chase
our career
with comedy clubs close yep so now we're
sitting in the city
we're paying crazy money to live in
these tiny little box apartments
we're paying crazy tax on the money that
we do make
because we live in the city how much
longer am i gonna keep paying that
when i don't get any amenities it's like
you know what it's like it's like being
friend zoned bro
like when you're friend zoned you got to
do all the [ __ ] [ __ ]
with that girl and you get none of the
benefits
of being with that girl you're paying an
emotional tax you're paying this
emotional tax so it's like if if rogan
was in la
he's supposed to make all this money in
la and not be able to go to the store
not be able to go to empire not be able
to do stand-up every single night and
pay all the tax which the only reason
he's paying it
is so that he has access to the store to
theaters
to the ocean to the [ __ ] snow if he
wants to do it to hunting all that other
[ __ ]
i'm willing to pay the new york city tax
the la tax whatever it is as long as the
city is providing me with the amenities
that's what we're paying attacks for
right you live in one of these apartment
complexes that got a pool yeah and
you're paying a pool fee
yeah best believe the pool's open the
second the pool ain't open
i'm not paying for that [ __ ] why the
[ __ ] am i paying why are we yo
i've never been more happy to live in
jersey i hate it i hate saying i live in
jersey but i'm paying half the rent
for to not be in the city to be in the
city right now the grocery stores suck
at constant traffic
everything is slow i'm paying three
times the rent two times the rent and i
got access to nothing call it out what
we live in the city for matter of fact
you're someone who moved to the city
what did you mean for stand-up comedy to
do what to be a
great stand-up comedian to have access
to the comedy clubs and that's the only
way that you could be a great stand-up
community if you have access comedy club
only reason i'm here
are there comedy clubs open no so
so should you pay two times the amount
of money
per month in rent absolutely get half
the amount of space absolutely not and i
think
people are leaving new york in droves
for that reason sam because everybody
came here for
not everybody most people came here for
a dream even if you're like an eye
banker who works on wall street and
that's why you came here
wall street you ain't getting in a
[ __ ] you're not getting down there
you're working from home
you're working from home if i'm working
from home why am i paying this money
wanna
i could have a bigger home bro do you
know that barbados
yesterday just put out this thing where
they're given
one year work visas this is genius
that's what we call
this is what we were talking about first
when corona hit remember when we were
doing the corona chronicles
and i was like yo people are gonna do
these like work communities where like
eight friends who all have jobs
different jobs but they're all working
from home
are like yo let's go to jackson hole and
live there for two months let's go to
mexico city and
live there for two months all you need
is internet connection
barbados is like yo why wouldn't you
just want to live on the beach for this
year if you're going to have to be at
home anyway
go do your work right out in your porch
that overlooks the water they can
collect
all that money hell yeah you know it's
not like if you're in new york granted
we're good for the summer because you
could eat out a nice restaurant still
you can get delivered once this winter
comes bro
what's keeping us here is the fact that
this studio is here what's keeping us
is the fact that the things that we
create are here
yeah but please believe if we were doing
[ __ ] on a [ __ ] zoom mic like a lot of
these people do their podcast
we could be anywhere in the world yep i
don't think the zoom when i meant zoom
mic is a different type of mic
the zoom calls yeah i think those are
trash awful
i don't think that they make that good
power but if we could do this in
barbados
i'm telling you let's go to barbados and
if there you might be paying tax but the
tax is for barbados
before you were paying attacks for new
york and new york was my dreams are here
you're not paying for a beach you're
paying for my dreams are here i got to
pursue my dreams when you can't pursue
your dreams
what are you paying the tax for some
states don't have
any tax that's why [ __ ] are
moving there yeah why would you not move
there
i mean look if i just got the craziest
bag sorry real quick
something about texas no state tax
that's why i was about to stay if i just
got this crazy back from spotify
i'm supposed to give california twelve
percent tax
which i haven't spoke i haven't spoken
to rogan about the money right but
if i'm rogan if andrew's rogan i get
this crazy deal i'm supposed to give
california twelve percent tax when
california ain't giving me twelve
percent
amenities you crazy you are out of your
mind
crazy if you think i'm gonna just give
you money and i get nothing from it now
i understand california's doing the
right thing by keeping everything shut
down
i get that but i as an independent
citizen have the right to do whatever i
want to live whatever the [ __ ] i want
and it might not see 12 don't sound high
if you're making 100 000
but what the reported rogan deal is and
we both think it's higher
is 100 million if california says 12
million dollars so you can live here
and get nothing out of it aren't you
going to be like go [ __ ] you california
let's go to texas or florida
when there's no state tax some people
think rogan is leaving specifically
because
of the spotify deal i would if well i
will say this if
the spotify deal was 100 million let's
just say
i don't i'm not counting spock's but it
was said he made like 30 million
a year doing the podcast regularly maybe
more
so the spotify deal is 100 for three
years let's say it was i think it's way
more i think it's like 200 but i don't
know for sure
if it is the hundred he's really not
making any more money doing spotify
so he was already comfortable paying
that tax in california as long as he
could do the [ __ ] that he wanted in
california
it's not like some some like people are
looking at this like he's being
uh like trying to avoid taxes or
something like that it's not that it's
just why would i pay this to be in a
place i don't want to be
i'll pay the tax if i'm getting my taxes
worth yeah if i'm not getting my taxes
worth
i'm out like honestly i'm thinking about
this [ __ ] right now it's like
the [ __ ] i wonder how many people are
just moving
and here's the other thing man what this
is forcing entertainment to do is
decentralize
so i don't think it stops with rogan i
think rogan is kind of always ahead of
the curve from what we're seeing
but it's going to become a thing where
you don't have to live in la we're all
making our own content now
so i can go to la because it's like a
lot of the people who want to make
content live there and we can think
together and brainstorm network whatever
but as we get more and more autonomous
in the way we make content
there is no hub where we have to live um
yeah man it's it's interesting it's like
you're only connected to
to the space where you create yeah you
know if you're someone who just has
sketches
you can go where the [ __ ] you want but
what happens when the clubs open back up
we don't know when that shit's gonna
happen bro and it just feels like it's
getting pushed and pushed no i'm talking
about rogan like he's
oh permanently really oh he's gonna just
try to like build up the scene out there
yeah and he he can and he's i don't i
personally as a texan don't really like
austin because everybody's like texas
sucks but austin is cool
yeah it's like not [ __ ] you but austin
has a good stand-up scene already they
have a decent scene
yeah they have a great festival that
moon tower yeah
festival is fire they have they have a
legit club called uh
cap city cap city heart is super fun is
a legit club so they have a [ __ ]
scene
and he could just be you know the the
lightning rod for that
and it's just if you're rogan if you're
at the level where andrew is getting
you're not you don't have to go to the
club every night i'm going to drop in
they're going to put me on stage when i
want to run some material and then if i
want to work out a longer set i'm on the
road whenever i want to be wherever i
want to be
every weekend he's going doing a theater
an arena if he needs to
i need in my position currently i still
need new york because i need access to
six seven clubs a night
and i gotta get my spots and fight for
my spots if you are rogan if you are
quite frankly where andrew is heading i
don't i'm going to drop in and you're
going to put me up whenever i want
so why do i have to be here when i just
i go work [ __ ] out in cap city
and then i'm flying somewhere this
weekend and i'm doing hour-long gigs in
theaters working my [ __ ] up
i don't need l.a i'll be honest with you
when we were on the road before corona
yeah
and we were doing shows every single
weekend yeah i was probably going up
once or twice a week because you don't
not only do not need it it's exhausting
and i'm
all i got to do is work some [ __ ] out if
i don't have new [ __ ] to work out
i don't need to go i'm dropping in for
fun i still got to drop in for work and
everything you
drop in for fun that's the thing it's
like i would go up
because there was something specific to
do and if you can have fun
at cap city why the [ __ ] do i gotta pay
12 million dollars
people don't get it's like when you're
coming up and doing comedy getting those
reps is so valuable
yes those 15 minute reps but when you're
on the road doing five shows
an hour each you can't come close to
five hours of comedy
doing 15 minute spots in the city in a
week you can't come close i mean just do
the math
yeah i mean what is that 20 spots yeah
you'd have to do in a week yeah
something like that and you can do that
but also doing a longer setting
you can breathe in a different way five
a night is crazy you're not doing five a
night
it's just crazy i'm sure there's some
workhorses who whatever like aaron burke
did
he did a first thing but he like twenty
eight and a nine you can't keep it up
also
be realistic no you cannot do it but
even beyond that
doing 30 minutes it feels so much
different and better than doing 15
because i get to breathe i get to let my
jokes breathe
you said you can do 20 spots a week
regularly no
no you can't you you can do it once in a
while you're not no
i'm there might be a comedian or two is
trying to sustain it you can't sustain
it right right
but also an hour long set even that
aside
is just different than 15. you just feel
different up there there's a different
pacing
you're breathing it's like a whole
different thing the way i look at it is
three on three versus five on five
that's [ __ ] great so like 15 minute
spots there's a nice little pickup game
at the gym ymca you're playing three on
three yeah
and when you do an hour that's 515 with
referees
yeah it's different it's a different
paces different intensity
and it's a different skill level
required you could get a guy who sucks
and he can play three on three and it's
okay yeah he's
in a game of five of five and it's like
you are exposed
yeah big time but yeah it's just
interesting to see what happens man like
all these different people moving
shaking like what happens with stand up
so many people
just their entire livelihood was based
on live performing
yeah you know like there's so many
people who just made their money
doing shows and now what happens like if
they don't have any other income
i don't know i wonder if a lot of people
are out of the game after this
can i ask you this so it's like in la it
seems like rogan has a crew
yeah that crew i wouldn't say they
depend on him but it's like
he's like the head of that crew who do
you think fills the spot
that's interesting man i i don't know i
mean like
the next biggest pod is obviously the
fighter and the kid but it's such a
different podcast
it's a hang it's not like a an
intellectual like expose every single
day
with rogan you're gonna have some like
scientists one day and then you're going
to have like
some like gambling addict turned
motivational speaker the next day like
andrew the next day yeah it's just so
random then like a comic race like
there's so many like it's such a random
thing
and i don't know who can recreate that
and also who has like
the knowledge and curiosity i think one
of the coolest things about a rogan
episode is that like
rogan kind of asks the questions that
you would ask
you know you're watching and you're like
oh okay this is not
like i for me it's less interesting to
have like two really sophisticated like
uh
thinkers about one specific subject like
two like intellectuals that just know
about evolutionary biology like speaking
to each other i'm less interested in
that
i want a really curious guy who's like
me
talking to the professor so he can ask
the [ __ ] questions i might be
embarrassed to ask
or i really feel like i need to know
rogan is
uh i think his greatest gift of all is
he is
pretty egoless and i think that's
perfect for an interviewer
either one of us we're interviewing
somebody we're gonna try to get our
jokes in we're gonna try to get our
validation in somehow
that's not a knock on us but it is i
marvel at rogan not needing that at all
he's just hey i'm already validated i'm
fulfilled
let's talk about what you're doing oh
this is cure that's interesting let's
talk about
and us as listeners we got no ego we
don't need to be we just want to know
talk to me like you would talk to a
regular person and rogan allows he's the
conduit to let that happen
talk to me like you talk to a regular
person right i'll ask questions i don't
need to be funny i don't need to gain
validation
what's going on here it'll be
interesting to see what happens man
you